pour regarder ce que j'ai reçus
aujourd'hui c'est juste dans ce petit
carton là alors vous le savez si vous
avez cliqué sur la vidéo c'est marqué
dans le titre comme ça vous pouvez pas
vous tromper c'est le nouvel imac c'est
la imac 27 pouces une très grande
proposition avec une très grosse machine
et je voulais l'ouvrir avec vous alors
seule machine que j'aurais dû recevoir
il ya quelques jours mais
malheureusement le transporteur la
décide autrement donc elle arrive avec
quelques jours de retard néanmoins on va
regarder à quoi elle ressemble je vais
vous détailler un peu quelles sont les
nouveautés d'un point de vue purement
technique
et puis d'ici quelques jours laissez moi
un petit peu de temps bien la prendre en
main on en repart âge donnerai mon
retour complet lors du test
regardez ça ça c'est quand même
relativement tout mignon c'est quand
même très très heureuse bête chapelle ya
toujours un art autour de l'oeil boxing
et là on le voit une fois de plus ce
qu'est ce qu'on y design by apple une
california on est sûr très jolie magic
qui bordent c'est vraiment ça que j'aime
avec la proposition qui est faite par
cette marque c'est vraiment un côté
extrêmement profilées côté design et
c'est vraiment c'est toujours assez
incroyable ce qu'on trouve du côté de
chapeau comme de proposition vous avez
la finesse du touquet est assez
impressionnant c'est hyper léger c'est
très cool et très agréable au toucher
comme ça on en reparlera dans quelques
jours lors du test d'ailleurs si ce
n'est pas déjà fait je vous invite à
venir vous abonner pour son petit bouton
rouge que vous avez là comme ça vous
saurez tout sur le test de cette belle
machine est bien évidemment surtout les
premiers hôtes ont pas parce qu'on a
bien évidemment d'ordi on parle de
smartphones on parle de tablettes de
tout ça on parle surtout de vous de
votre vie numérique de vos usages donc
abonnez vous qu'est ce petit bout tombe
à actionner la crèche comme ça vous
serez notifié dès qu'une nouvelle vidéo
arrivera puis vous serez sur tout et ça
c'est vraiment hyper hyper courts à
tourner parce que ça ne s'arrête pas là
on a autre chose à l'intérieur une magic
mouse
j'adore vraiment le travail qu'ils font
là dessus on est si des petits trucs sur
leymen petit dock nettoyage de l'écran
que toutes les infos pratiques
ça c'est vachement bien un petit câble
lightning pour venir recharger sa souris
[Musique]
on est un petit peu moins de neuf kilos
on a eu huit kilos 92 jour là j'ai mon
câble d'alimentation
l'idée de lyme accès que vous avez votre
petit pied comme ça votre écran qui va
venir pivoter pour venir installer comme
vous le souhaitez c'est très précis
comme vous êtes sur une machine un peu
tout en effet ce qui est génial c'est
que vous avez tout à l'intérieur bon je
vais pas vous refaire une fois l'animal
c'est pas une toute nouvelle machine
mais cette version 27 pouces est
vraiment extrêmement intéressant parce
que ça vous permet d'avoir un énorme
écran complètement dégagé ça c'est
génial
vous avez juste un branding apple et si
vous avez une caméra en 1080p et tout le
reste si tu arrêtes votre machine et on
voulait pas le louper si vous avez
vraiment brandy qui est énorme apple un
petit trou ici pour venir pas passer
votre câble d'alimentation et vous
retrouvez les connectiques sur le côté
prise jack un lecteur de cartes sdxc
vous avez 4 usb vous avez deux usb c'est
thunderball 3 avec prise en charge de
display port
et vous avez une prise ethernet ici avec
une option d gigabit et si l'autre côté
vous entrez votre petit mouton pour
venir la vue mais j'avais des haut
parleurs stéréo qui vous avait pas moins
de trois micros qualité studio alors
l'idée de ces micro qualité studio c'est
pas faire de l'enregistrement de voix si
vous allez venir chanter et créer un
morceau s'est passé à l'idée l'idée
c'est que lorsque vous allez avoir une
conférence vous allez parler à quelqu'un
de votre caméra facetime est située
juste à l'avant une folle dit une fois
de plus en 1080 l'idée c'est de revenir
à optimiser la qualité de votre voix en
supprimant tous les soins extérieurs
parasites regardez par exemple j'en dors
qu'ils foutent ils acquis et planqueel
si on a ici un écran retina 5k 5120 par
2008 180 pixels
on a 14 ans est mis en couleur une
luminance de 500 dit mais surtout on a
ici à technologie true tonnes une gamme
de couleurs p3 notamment pour tous les
créatifs et surtout c'est en option on
inverse qui est innée knowtex tueur
alors ici ça vous parlera pas forcément
le regardant comme ça nous permet de
réduire significativement les reflets
tout en préservant les contrastes les
couleurs et compagnie s'est retrouvé des
processeurs intel core 2 10
même génération vous allez partir d'un
intel core i5 à 3,1 gigahertz jusqu'à
1,9 à 3,6 giguère pour c'est vraiment à
venir étudier vos besoins avant d'aller
sur notre configuration tout en vous
disant que à l'avenir il se peut que vos
besoins évoluent donc il faut pas
hésiter quand même à se projeter un peu
dans l'avenir dans les cinq à dix ans je
sais que c'est compliqué on pouvait
vraiment la bonne config oui si vous
n'avez pas moins de quatre slots de
mémoire c'est de la ddr4 vous pouvez
aller de 8 gigas de ram jusqu'à 128 giga
de ram c'est assez énorme avant vous
pouviez aller jusqu'à 64 ce que tu es
déjà très très très bien le temps
pourrait monter jusqu'à 128 une fois de
plus il faut vraiment venir
calculez vos besoins savoir ce dont vous
avez réellement besoin avant d'aller
acheter 128 giga demain parce que tout
ça va me coûter très cher mais ce qui
est intéressant à savoir si comme vous
avez quatre slots il voulait faire
évoluer votre machine à l'avenir est
bien vous pouvez le faire aux points qui
est vachement intéressant vous avez un
ssd de série vous allez de 256 gigajoule
jusqu'à 8 et a une fois de plus et comme
pour votre processeur comme pour votre
mémoire
il faut vraiment que vous anticipez vos
besoins pour vraiment avoir le stockage
adaptés à vos besoins actuels mais à vos
besoins futurs
je sais que c'est dur mais il faut se
projeter en tout cas pas essayer côté
graphique on a ici une radio pro 5300
aka giga de mémoire c'est la ddr 6 et
sont les versions i7 et u9 vous pouvez
avoir une radio pro 5500 xt avec 8 giga
de mémoire toujours là de l'exercice
vous pouvez également avoir une radio
pro 5700 avec toujours 8 gigas de ram
ddr 6 mais également une radio pro 5700
xtc ce que j'ai ici avec 16 giga de
mémoire ddr six journées sur macos
catalina qui va pouvoir évoluer grâce à
une mise à jour 10 6 très très très très
peu d'options dix jours côté sécurité on
à la puce t2 d'apple permettra notamment
un démarrage sécurisé qui permettra de
chiffrer vos données alors bien
évidemment wifi bluetooth un camp tout
ça vous savez c'est normal sur une
machine comme ça c'est le grand minimum
regarder elle est en train de tout me
récupérer tout ce que j'ai en ligne dans
le club ça c'est vraiment finale et
c'est un des points qui est extrêmement
performant extrêmement important avec
apple c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle en tout cas moi j'utilise
l'écosystème apple tout ce que je vais
retrouver dans mon macbook pro est bien
regarder tu pourra le retrouver ici dans
l'imac 27 pouces ça s'est vraiment bien
longs qu'à toute cette question
d'écosystèmes qui est extrêmement
important de chez apple et qui fait que
tous les pros
vous allez trouver en tout cas chez
apple fonctionne très bien ensemble et
vous permet d'avoir une expérience
complètement maximiser et
personnellement c'est vraiment ce que je
vais venir apprécier
alors je suppose que vous vous en
douterez mais cette jolie machine et
avancent bien évidemment vous pouvez
l'acheter dans le commerce d'ailleurs si
elle vous intéresse vous alliez un lien
en bas dans la description votre config
que vous la faites à votre sens en
fonction de vos besoins
moi je veux vraiment vous parler
aujourd'hui du 27 pouces vous partez
d'un intel core de deuxième génération
d'un i5 cadencé à 3,1 gigahertz avec 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage et je
vous dis une fois de plus en ssd vous
êtes à 2099 euros vous êtes donc à 2011
vous n'avez pas le verbe et aux textures
et vous n'avez pas à l'import ethernet
en 10 gigas vous êtes vraiment sûr la
base ça c'est bien mais 256 go de
stockage pour moi c'est un peu petit
bien évidemment ça dépend de vous de vos
besoins d'ailleurs dit moi voir un
commentaire
quelles pourraient être vos besoins
actuels et vos besoins futurs 512 ça
pète le million d'enfants fonction de
vos projets mes intérêts c'est quand
même vachement bien si vous êtes en
dessous d'un terrain vous risquez d'être
endettés à l'avenir ou devoir faire
beaucoup de sauvegarde sur disque
externe est arrivé un moment où voilà
c'est pas forcément ceux qu'on a envie
de faire si par exemple vous restez sur
un i5 que vous le prenez cadencé à 3 3
giga hertz avec 8 gigas de ram 512 il ya
de stockage toujours en ssd parce que
oui cette série et bien vous êtes à 2299
euros alors moi la config que j'ai ici
j'ai un intel core i9 un terrain de
stockage j'ai 32 gigas de ram
côté graphique j'ai une radio pro 5700
xt et j'ai l'écran avec le verre nano
texturé et mac enfui coûte cinq mille
trois cents à 54 euros voyez c'est une
somme mais ça dépend une fois de plus de
vos besoins de ce que vous allez en
faire je vous le redis je vous le redis
à chaque fois vous parle d'un guet-apens
c'est vraiment une fois plus à vos
usages actuels parce que souvent on dit
tiens je vais acheter story parce que
j'ai besoin de faire ça mais de la
création je fais si je fais ça mais
pensez vraiment au besoin vous allez
avoir à l'avenir
avec le temps les fichiers pelles de
plus en plus lourdes les logiciels font
de plus en plus gourmand alors c'est
même peut-être pas sur cinq ans avec une
machine comme ça qui est quand même
extrêmement performante mais il faut
vraiment anticiper ça parce que je vous
le dis vous retrouvé bloqué dans 5 ans 5
7 ans ce serait vraiment dommage puisque
cette machine bien évidemment vous allez
à garder un minimum 5 7 ans voire 10
et plus l'affinité enfin ça dépend en
fait plus de vous et de vos yeux et si
vous partez sur la plus grosse config
inferno textures et sans notes il gît
gars de ram
la carte graphique la plus haute le 10
gigabits en ethernet le ssd high viterra
et bien vous arrivez sur une addition a
dit 1878 oui c'est très cher mais c'est
ce qu'on va retrouver de musan cette
machine donc ça rate une fois de plus
cohérent et ses pattes ou non qui aura à
ses besoins en termes de configuration
donc voilà pour ce qu'on pouvait dire
aujourd'hui de cette découverte de ce
produit cette première prise en main et
sortons d'un imac 27 pouces de 2020 je
le trouve extrêmement cool
j'aime beaucoup il a fait c'est ça c'est
plutôt l'idée du design un pay de ce que
nous propose apple c'est petite souris
très légère c'est un magic qui bordent
qui est vraiment hypra canaux cet
ordinateur qui est monstrueux
je vais le poser sur mon bureau chez moi
tranquillement je vais travailler puis
je faire du montage dessus et je vous
donnerai mon retour d'ici quelques jours
donc une fois de plus de 8 à vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous saurez tout dès qu'on en
parle dans un film bien évidemment des
comparé à 2 pas notre sujet pascal 26-1
hypra cool qui arrive sur ce vous invite
à prendre soin de vous faites attention
vous pouvez les gros bisous et puis ne
sais pas mais évidemment un poser toutes
vos questions interrogations en bas en
commentaire je les regarderai et on en
reparlera dans la vidéo de test nous on
remarque beaucoup d'amour a très vite
cas aucun
[Musique]